(crowd cheering)
(dramatic music)
(engine starting)
(tires screeching)
(horns honking)
We appreciate your service.
Enjoy this selfie free of charge.
Stay in school.
Education is important.
(audience laughing)
I like your car.
Nicely done.
(small motor whining)
That's pathetic.
Halt.
Halt woman.
In the purple dress.
Who is this guy?
That's your husband?
Come with me.
Come get in the car.
(audience laughing)
Goodbye husband.
She's mine now.
(audience cheering)
(audience laughing)
(beeping)
(electric motor whining)
(audience laughing)
I want a ride.
(applause)
What the hell was that?
I literally had like five people;
I had my thumb out; and they had plenty of room
and they would just high five me and keep on going.
(audience laughing)